hello reject nation it's Greg Alva air
and I'm John so we're gonna watch the
trailer teaser for spider-man into the
spider verse that animated movie we've
been hearing so much about from Sony
December 10th still don't have access to
the channel right now it's the day we're
filming this right here with that in
mind we wanted to give a shout out and a
big thank you to the real rejects video
sponsor Stardust
yes Stardust is this app that allows you
to do 30-second reactions for any film
TV show or trailer a lot of your
favorite youtubers are using this app
right now including us we post weekly I
would say probably every other day at
least it's allowing us to stay busy
while we're you know don't have access
to the channel right now trying to get
Tyrone Magnus involved on this app would
love to have Tyrone over there so want
you guys message him for us thank you to
Jake for being understanding what we're
working on this random thing that happen
with our channel yeah in terms of
sponsorships they're easily the best
sponsor we've ever had please show some
support and download the app and follow
us first at the real rejects link in the
description box people shout out today
to Gareth hood
[Music]
[Music]
Peter Parker's dead
that's cool
the old 90
Wow
[Music]
ah
it's cool whoo
[Music]
it's into the spider-verse
the main characters gonna be Miles
Morales but there's gonna be multiple
spider-man this is very interesting I
wonder how they're gonna handle this I
mean first off in terms of what we're
seeing here the animation style
definitely different than what I was
anticipating when I heard they were
making this yeah it does have this kind
of edgy gritty miss for teenagers yeah
it feels like it's hand-drawn they did
something to the motion quality where it
almost looked like like a stop motion or
sight those motion comics that was yeah
but moves more fluid and smoothly the
images looked super awesome you know
Stark feels like a comic book yeah you
know in a new way I haven't seen an
animated movie like this yet you know in
this style but I think it's a great
choice oh yes it's you know it's
different from the hand-drawn look but
also it looks like spider-man and his
powers and stuff are gonna really pop
and come to life in a place like this
and now I just hope the story's good
time yeah what's especially exciting
about it too is that for the longest
time we've been wanting to get a Miles
Morales into the movies you know when
they heard that it would be rebooting
spider-man with Home Coming people were
kind of speculated they might actually
have Miles Morales be that spider-man
and now we get the chance to introduce
Miles Morales to the world because
there's still a lot of people who don't
know who Miles Morales is I don't even
really know the details of Miles Morales
like I think what I've heard about this
specific movie is that he comes from an
alternate universe that caused the death
of Peter Parker to occur well so I don't
imagine that Peter Parker is like
officially gone from this world this is
from Sony too and I know Sony has their
own little Spidey verse going on yeah
which I'm so I don't know if this
animated movie is in direct correlation
with the Sony spider-man movies like a
movie is a Canon with those moves yes
you know I'm really unsure what they're
doing with it but right now we're
getting as a standalone film and a
Maserati oh this suit looks great the
animation looks great I'm excited for
everyone to get to know Miles Morales
especially me this looks like a pretty
bomb movie I can't wait Matt yeah maybe
a little Chris Miller working on the
story come on plus the next time they
reboot spider-man maybe now we can do
huh yeah because more people will
actually know who he is now yeah yeah
before this video is done we got to give
a shout out to Garrett hood this guy
sent us a message on patreon since we've
been going through all this stuff and I
told him I'm gonna screenshot this
message he says something here that I
thought was was very fitting for the
mood I was specifically in that day he
bought YouTube he bought YouTube he's
giving us the channel and everyone
else's tough times put things in
perspective and all I can do is what is
in your hands your attitude feelings and
actions are all in your hands and quite
simply if they don't help your situation
then change the approach we often tell
ourselves that the situation makes us
feel angry or upset whilst in reality we
choose how we feel glad that you're not
taking a positive approach you can only
do what's in your hands you're
absolutely right because in this whole
challenge we've had the first few days
was just a very negative mindset in the
past few days we've been learning a lot
about ourselves I feel like I especially
have been in terms of perspective on so
many different things it's been kind of
fun still filming without knowing what
exactly is gonna happen with these
videos thank you for being so supportive
because you are our top pledge on
patreon since the very beginning you
have been our highest pledge and beyond
that the the support the moral support
the interaction you have with us you and
your son Yusuf has has been one of the
most memorable highlights of the entire
year of having a patreon you guys like
you and Yusuf have really helped make it
something that is much more personable
we like to say our patrons the second
YouTube channel slash website and we
also say it's more of a personable site
because of the kind of interactions that
you and Yusuf have given us so thank you
for sharing your heart with us and
sharing so much of your emotional
support it really has made a difference
thank you as far as you Yousef I feel
like you could be in the spider-verse
do you have the quippy witty type of
banter with your dad you're young I
could see you being a future spider-man
I feel like Yousef probably already is
and Gareth probably builds all of his
suit yeah that's why we can never find
out what he does that's why they live in
Dubai cuz all the buildings are so high
yeah
as always posting pics you know yeah I'm
like maybe that's why maybe Youssef is
just a few floors I'm fighting crime and
you're just hanging out looking at cars
well guys you can subscribe to the real
rejects please click that notification
bell make sure to download and follow us
first on the Stardust app and become a
patron oject today it's one of the few
places we're actively posting a
Hunstanton